si monsieur alain fouché pour le groupe
ump monsieur le président mes chers
collègues madame la ministre je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur deux points
le premier concerne le financement de la
réforme des rythmes scolaires
la caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales devraient concourir avec
l'état au financement du fonds
d'amorçage destiné à aider les communes
dans la mise en place de la réforme qui
représente un coût important pour les
collectivités
le président de la cnaf a indiqué
récemment qu'il n'aurait
vraisemblablement pas les moyens de
financer une telle réforme d'autant que
la cnape intervient déjà auprès des
communes
l'inquiétude des maires qui ont choisi
de mettre en place la réforme à la
rentrée de septembre 2013
grandi car tous sont intégrés à leur
budget la dotation qui était prévu pour
la mise en oeuvre des nouveaux rythmes
et naturellement le compte financier n'y
est pas le deuxième point sur lequel
devrait vous interrogez mais ça a été
évoqué mais ça concerne toutes les
caisses il s'agit du manque d'effectifs
au sein de cette institution est dans
mon département aussi qui est celui de
la vienne le retard de traitement des
demandes de rs en particulier dans
l'ouverture des droits peut avoir des
incidences graves pour les bénéficiaires
le nombre de ces dossiers a
considérablement augmenté ces derniers
temps a contrario les moyens pour
traiter ces demandes n'ont pas progressé
il finit le traitement de délai prévu de
dix jours a été difficile à respecter
depuis le début de l'année 2013 la
question des effectifs est donc capital
maintenir voire renforcer les structures
locales semble donc opportun dans le
contexte actuel madame la ministre
pouvez vous me donner des éléments
chiffrés sur l'évolution des effectifs
ainsi que sur la participation de la
cnaps au financement de la réforme des
rythmes scolaires dans le ministre
sur les effectifs je ne reviendrai pas
sur ce que j'ai pu déjà indiqué au cours
des différentes réponses sur la sur la
réforme
et des rythmes scolaires vous voyez
qu'il faut toujours être prudent je le
dis puisque vous citiez les propos de
monsieur de roussent puisque il est très
clairement il sera signifié très
clairement qu'un fonds de 250 millions
d'euros sera affecté au financement de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires
et que cette dépense nouvelle de 250
millions vient s'ajouter aux crédits qui
sont déjà consacrés au financement du
temps périscolaire
l'accompagnement financier prend deux
formes c'est à dire qu'à titre
exceptionnel lac à la cnaf pardon
versera une participation financière au
fonds d'amorçage au titre de l'année
2014 et à titre personnel la branche
famille participera au financement de la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme des rythmes
éducatif par l'intermédiaire d'une
prestation de services spécifiques
cette prestation sera versée aux
accueils organisée dans le cadre d'un
projet éducatif territorial et aux
accueils respectant la réglementation
édictée par la branche famille cette
aide est destinée à participer au
financement des heures de temps
périscolaire supplémentaires induites
par la réforme et elle sera versée en
fonction du nombre d'élèves fréquentant
les accueils dans la limite de trois
heures par semaine et de 36 semaines par
an on sait dès à présent que le montant
annuel de l'aide sera d'environ 53 euros
par élève qu'il sera régulièrement
valeur revalorisé cela veut dire que
pour les communes qui se sont engagés
dès la rentrée 2013 2014 dans la réforme
des rythmes scolaires elles vont
bénéficier à la fois du fonds d'amorçage
et du fonds versés par la cnaf fonds
d'amorçage c'est autour de 50 euros font
de la cnaf 53 euros alors que l'on sait
que le coût global d'une heure est de
l'ordre de 130 euros donc vous voyez que
l'effort qui est fait pour aider
justement
ces communes a assumé la la réforme des
rythmes scolaires est tout à fait
important est conséquente merci monsieur
fouchana ministre bon sur des effectifs
il faut renforcer les effectifs et mais
des emplois d'avenir c'est très bien
mais à la condition qu'ils soient
pérennisés comme l'ont été d'autres
emplois mais ça ne suffira pas forcément
deuxièmement sur les rythmes scolaires
dans tout ceci était décidée rapidement
sans véritable concertation mais je note
que vous demandez à la cnav de faire un
effort mais l'effort n'est pas suffisant
naturellement pour les communes
puisqu'il ya des aides de l'état ne
seront pas forcément pérenniser les
aides de la cnaps notre pas forcément
pérenniser donc les communes connaissent
des difficultés on rencontre les maires
on le sait c'est très difficile pour et
surtout le même vers les conseillers
généraux pour demander qu'on les aide
financièrement donc je crois que dans ce
domaine puisque des talents annoncé
cette procédure il faut que l'état fasse
plus cela me paraît utile et important